the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
yesterday we've learnt about flux and
we've seen the first few examples of how
to set up and compute integrals for flux
of a vector field for a surface so
remember the flux of a vector field F
for the surface s is defined by taking
the double integral on the surface of f
dot NDS where n is the unit normal to
the surface and D s is the area element
on the surface so as we've seen for
various surfaces we have various
formulas telling us what the normal
vector is and what we our element
becomes for example on spheres we
typically integrate with respect to fee
and theta the latitude and longitude
angles on a horizontal plane we would
just end up decorating DX dy and so on
so at the end of lecture we saw a
formula and what if you ask me how did
we get it well we didn't get it yet so
we're going to try to explain where it
comes from and why it works okay so the
case we want to look at is if s is the
graph of a function so you know it's
given by Z equals some function in terms
of x and y so our surface is out here Z
is a function of x and y and x and y
will range over some domain in the XY
plane namely well the region that's the
shadow of the surface on the XY plane
so I said that will have a formula for
NDS which will end up being plus minus
minus F sub X minus F sub y one dxdy so
that we will set up and evaluate the
integral in terms of x and y replacing
every time we see Z we will replace it
by f of X Y whatever the formula for F
might be so by the way I mean see if
actually if we look at the very easy
case where this is just a horizontal
plane so Z equals constant the function
is just a constant well the partial
derivatives become just zero you get
zero zero one dxdy
that's what you would expect for a
horizontal plane just from common sense
so this is more interesting of course if
a function is more interesting so how do
we get that where does this come from so
we need to figure out for a small piece
of our surface what will be n Delta s if
you want so let's say that we take a
small rectangle in here corresponding to
sides Delta X and Delta Y and we look at
the piece of surface that's above that
well the question we have now is what is
the area of this little piece of surface
and what is its normal vector so observe
this little piece up here if it's small
enough it will look like a parallelogram
it might be slightly curvy but roughly
it looks like a parallelogram in space
and so we've seen how to find the area
of a parallelogram in space using
cross-product right if we can figure out
what are the vectors for this side and
that side then taking the cross product
will give us and taking the magnitude of
the cross product will give us the area
maava the cross product also gives us
the normal direction
so in fact the cross-product gives us
two in one it gives us the normal
direction and the other element and
that's why I said that we will have an
easy formula for NDS while N and D s
taken separately are more complicated
because you'd have to actually take the
length of a direction
of this game okay so let's carry out
this problem so let's say I'm going to
look at a small piece of the XZ plane
the side the XY plane so here I have
Delta X e I have Delta Y and I'm
starting at some point X Y now above
that I will have a parallelogram on my
surface I need to figure out so this
point here the point where I start I
know what it is it's just X Y and LZ is
f of X Y so now what I want to find
actually is what are these two vectors
let's call them U and V that correspond
to moving a bit in the X direction or in
the Y direction and when you cross V
will be well in terms of the magnitude
of this guy will just be the little
piece of surface area Delta s and in
terms of direction it will be normal to
the surface so it will be May actually I
will get just Delta s times my normal
vector well up to sign because depending
on whether I do u cos V or V cos u I
might get the normal vector in the
direction I want or in the opposite
direction but we'll take care of that
later up to sign
okay so let's find U and V so in case
you have trouble with that small picture
when I have a better one here
let's keep it just in case you know in
case this one gets really too cluttered
it really represents the same thing okay
so let's try to figure out these vectors
U and V so the vector u starts at the
point x y f of X Y and it goes to where
as its head well I'll have moved X by
Delta X so X plus Delta X Y doesn't
change and of course the Z coordinate
has to change it becomes f of X plus
Delta X and y now how does F change if I
change X a little bit well we've seen
that it's given by the partial
derivative F sub X so this is
approximately equal to f of XY plus
Delta x times F sub X at the given point
XY I'm not going to edit because
notation is already long enough so that
means my vector U is well approximately
because I'm using this linear
approximation Delta X 0 and F sub x
times Delta X ok is that okay with
everyone good
now what about V well V works the same
way okay so I'm not going to do all the
details when I move from here to here
well X doesn't change and Y changes by
Delta Y so X component nothing happens
Y component changes by Delta Y what
about the Z component well F changes by
F sub y times Delta Y that's how f
changes if I increase Y by Delta Y okay
so I have my two sides now we can take a
cross product well maybe I will first so
I factor something out see I can provide
this as 1 0 F sub x times Delta X and
this one I will rewrite as 0 1 F sub y
Delta Y and so now the cross product so
n hat Delta s up to sign it's going to
be u cos V u cos V well so we'll have to
do the cross product and we'll have a
Delta X Delta Y coming out ok I'm just
you know saving myself a trouble of
finding a lot of Delta X and Delta Y is
but if you prefer you can just do
directly this cross product
okay so let's compute this cross-product
well the I component is 0 minus F sub X
the y component is going to be well f
sub y minus 0 but with a minus sign in
front of everything so negative F sub y
and the Z component will be just 1 times
Delta X Delta Y ok does that make sense
for yes very good and so now when we
just take in a which rank respect angle
we find Delta X and Delta Y to 0 that's
how we get this formula for NDS equals
negative f X negative f y one dxdy well
plus minus because it's it's up to us to
choose whether we want to take the
normal vector pointing up or down so see
if you take this convention then the Z
component of NDS is positive so that
corresponds to normal vector pointing up
if you take the opposite signs then the
Z component will be negative that means
your normal vector points down okay so
this one is with an pointing up I mean
when I say up of course it's still
perpendicular to the surface you know
the surface is really has a big slope
when it it's not really going to go all
that much up but more up then down okay
so that's how we get that formula any
questions
nope
okay so that's a really useful formula
so you don't really need to remember all
the details of how we got it but please
remember that formula let's do an
example actually so let's say I want to
find the flux of the vector field Z
times K so it's a vertical vector field
for the portion of the paraboloid Z
equals X square plus y squared that
lives above the unit disc okay so what
does that mean Z equals x squared plus y
squared well we've seen it many times
okay it's this parabola weight pointing
up above the unit disk means I only care
about I don't care about this infinite
surface I will actually stop when I hit
a radius of one away from the z axis and
so now I have my vector field which is
going to point over all up because well
Z times K so the more Z is positive the
modular vector field goes up because if
Z we are negative then it would point
down but we live above so actually a
quick opinion pearl what do you think
the flux should be should be positive
zero negative we don't know okay so I
see some I don't know I see some
negative and I see some positive so of
course I didn't tell you which way I'm
orienting my power below it so so far
both answers are correct the only one
that's probably not correct is zero
because no matter which way you twist
oriented you should get something it's
not it's not looking like it will be
zero so let's say that I'm going to do
it with a normal point
upwards so second chance okay see some
people changing back and forth between
one and two
okay so let's draw a picture which one
is pointing upwards well let's look at
the bottom point the normal vector
pointing up here we know what it means
it's this guy and so if you continue to
follow your normal vector C the actually
pointing up and into the paraboloid okay
and I claim that the answer should be
positive because the vector field is
crossing our power below it going
upwards going from the outside out and
below to the inside and up side so in
the direction which were counting
positively well we'll see how it turns
out when we do the calculation okay so
we have to compute the integral for flux
double integral over the surface of f
dot NDS is going to be okay so what are
we going to do well F we say it is zero
zero Z what is NDS well let's use our
brand-new formula so it says negative F
sub X negative F sub y one dxdy what is
little F in here it's x squared plus y
squared okay so when we are using this
formula we need to know what we you know
what little F stands for is whatever the
formula is for Z as a function of x and
y so we take x squared plus y squared
and we take the partial derivatives with
minus signs we get negative 2x negative
2y and one dxdy well of course here I
didn't really matter because we're going
to dot them with zero so actually even
if we had make you know if we even if we
had made a mistake we somehow wouldn't
have had to pay the price but still okay
so we'll end up with double integral on
s of Z DX dy now what do we do with that
well we have to many things we need to
get rid of Z so let's use Z equals x
square plus y square once more
okay so that becomes double integral of
x squared plus y squared DX dy and here
see we're using the fact that we're only
looking at things that are on the
surface it's not like in the triple
integral you could never do that because
Z x and y are independent here they're
related by the equation of the surface
so if I sound like I'm you know one
thing but I know from experience this is
where you know one of the most sticky
and tricky points is actually that's
okay so now how will we actually
integrate that well now that we have
just x and y we should figure out what's
the range for x and y well the range for
x and y is going to be the shadow of our
region it's going to be this unit disk
okay so let me just do that for now and
say here this is finally where I've left
the world of surface integrals to go
back to a usual double integral and now
I have to set it up what I can do it
this way with DX dy but it looks like
there's a smarter thing to do I'm going
to use actually polar coordinates so in
fact I'm going to say this is double
integral of R squared times Rd Rd theta
I'm on the unit disk so I'll go 0 to 1
theta goes 0 to 2pi and if you do the
calculation you'll find that this is
going to be PI over 2 okay
any questions about the example yes okay
how do I get how did I get this negative
2x and negative 2y so I want to use my
formula for NDS okay my surface is given
by the graph of a function it's the
graph of a function X square plus y
squared so I will use this formula
that's up here I will take the function
X square plus y squared
they will take its partial derivatives
so if I take the partial of F so if x
squared plus y squared respect to X I
get 2x so I put negative 2x and then
same thing negative 2y one dxdy yes
which K had oh you mean the vector field
well so it's a different part of the
story okay so whenever you do a surface
integral for flux you have two parts of
the story one is the vector field whose
flux you're taking the other one is the
surface for which you will be taking
flux so the vector field only comes as
you know this F in Venetian and
everything else the bounds on the double
integral and the NDS they all come from
the surface that we are looking at okay
so basically in all of this calculation
this is coming from F equals ZK
everything else comes from the
information paraboloid Z equals X square
plus y squared above the unit disk okay
so in particular if we wanted to now
find you know the flux of any other
vector field for the same paraboloid
well all we have to do is just replace
this guy by whatever the new vector
field is we've learned how to set up
flux integrals for this paraboloid not
that you should remember this one by
heart I mean there's many paraboloid in
life and other surfaces too so the data
to remember of a general method okay any
other questions nope
okay let's see more ways of tec-9 flux
integrals but just to reassure you at
this point we've seen the most important
ones you know ninety percent of the
problems that we'll be looking at we can
do with what we've seen so far last time
and this and this formula but let's look
a little bit at a more general situation
let's say that my surface is so
complicated that I can't actually
express Z as a function of x and y but
let's say that actually I know how to
parameterize it so I have damping
equation for my surface that means I can
express XY and Z in terms of any two
parameter variables that might be
relevant for me so if you want this one
here is the special case where you can
parameterize things in terms of X and y
as your two variables so how would you
do it in the fully general case in a way
that will answer your question I think
one of you I forgot asked yesterday how
would I do it in general it's got a
formula like MDX plus NDY well that's
going to be the general formula and
you'll see it's a little bit too
complicated so we're really useful ones
actually the special ones so let's say
that we are given a parametric
description of a surface s so that means
we can describe s by formulas saying X
is some function of two parameter
variables I'm going to call them U and V
hope you don't mind you can call them t1
and t2 you can call them whatever you
want okay so one of the basic qualities
of a surface is because I have only two
independent directions to move on I
should be able to express XY and Z in
terms of two variables so now let's say
that I know how to do that or maybe I
should instead think of it in terms of a
position vector if it helps you the
position vector
oh that's just the vector with
components X Y Z is given as a function
of U and V okay so it works like a
parametric curve but with two parameters
so now how will we actually set up a
flux integral on such a surface well
because we are locating ourselves in
terms of U and V we will end up with an
integral D U DV so we need to figure out
how to express NDS in terms of D U and V
V okay so NDS should be something dudv
how do we do that well we can use the
same method that we've actually used
over here because if you think for a
second you know here we used of course a
rectangle in the xy-plane and we lifted
it to a parallelogram and so on but
marginally you can think what happens if
I change u by Delta u keeping V constant
or the other way around you know you
will get some sort of mesh grid on your
surface and you will look at a little
parallelogram
that's an elementary piece of that mesh
and figure out what is its area and
normal vector
well that will again be given by the
normal by the cross product of the two
sides okay so let's think a little bit
about what happens when I move a little
bit on my surface so you know I'm taking
a clear grade on my surface given by the
U and V directions and if I take a piece
of that corresponding to small changes
Delta U and Delta V what's going to be
going on here
well I have to deal with two vectors one
corresponding to changing u the other
one cost me to changing thee if I change
u
how does my point change well that's
given by the derivative of this with
respect to u okay so this vector here I
will
all so the sides are given by let me say
partial R over partial u times Delta u
if you prefer maybe I should write it as
partial X partial u Delta u partial Y
well just to go into white so and so on
okay it means just you know if I change
you a little bit keep V constant then
how exchanges is given by partial X
partial u times Delta u same thing with
Y something with Z and I'm just using
vector notation to do it this way if you
want that's nobody analog of when I said
Delta R for line integrals along a curve
vector Delta R is the velocity vector
dr/dt times delta T now if I look at the
other side
the others okay so sorry let me start
again
and out of space one side is partial a
partial u times Delta U and the other
one would be partial R partial V times
Delta V because that's how the position
of your point changes if you just change
U or V and not the other one
so now to find the surface element
together with a normal vector I would
just take the cross-product between
these guys so if you prefer that the
cross-product of partial R partial U
with partial R partial V Delta u Delta V
and so NDS is this cross-product times D
u DV up to sign I mean also here depends
on which choice I make for my normal
vector of course
okay now if you you know but of course
is a slightly confusing equation to
think of so a good exercise if you want
to really understand what's going on try
this in two good examples to look at one
good example to look at is the previous
one what is it it's when u and V are
just x and y okay so the poetic
equations are just x equals x y equals y
and z is f of XY you should end up with
the same formula that we had over there
and you should see why because see it's
both of them are given by the cross
product the other case you can look at
just to convince yourselves even further
so we don't need to do that because
we've seen the formula before but in the
case of a sphere we've seen the formula
for n and for D s separately so we know
what NDS are in terms of D Phi D theta
well you could parameterize a sphere in
terms of 3 and theta
namely the formulas would be x equals a
sine Phi cosine theta y equals a sine
Phi sine theta Z equals a cosine Phi the
formulas for spherical coordinates
setting or equals a so that's a
parametric equation for the sphere and
then if you try to use this formula here
you should end up with the same things
we've already seen for NDS just with a
lot more pain to actually get there
because your cross product is going to
be a bit complicated okay but you know
we're seeing all of these formulas they
all fit together somehow it's always the
same question just we have different
angles of attack on this general problem
okay questions
nope okay
let's look at yet another last way of
finding NDS and when I promise we'll
switch to something else because I can
feel that you are getting a bit
overwhelmed by all these formulas for
NDS
so okay so what happens very often is we
don't actually know how to parameterize
our surface maybe we don't know how to
solve for Z as a function of x and y but
our surface is given by some equation no
and so what that means is actually maybe
what we know is not really these kinds
of formulas but maybe we know a normal
vector I'm going to call this one
capital n because I don't even need it
to be a unit vector you will see it can
be a normal vector of any length you
want to the surfaces so why would we
ever know a normal vector well for
example if our surface is a plane you
know set a slanted plane given by some
equation ax plus B Y plus C's equals D
well you know the normal vector it's ABC
of course you could solve for Z and then
go back to that case which is where I
said where that one is very useful but
you can also just stay with a normal
vector Y why else would you know a
normal vector well let's say that you
know an equation that's a form G of X Y
Z equals zero well when you know that
the gradient of G is perpendicular to
the level surface okay so let me just
give you two examples if you have a
plane ax plus B Y
plus C's equals D then the normal vector
would just be ABC if you have a surface
s given by an equation G of X Y Z equals
zero then you can take the normal vector
to be the gradient of G we've seen that
the gradient is perpendicular to the
level surface now of course we don't
necessarily have to follow what's going
to come because if we could solve for Z
then we might be better off doing what
we did over there but let's say that we
want to do it this way so then what can
we do well I'm going to give you another
way to think jiayou metrically about NDS
so
okay so let's start by thinking about
the slanted plane okay so let's say that
my surface is just a slanted plane so my
normal vector would be maybe somewhere
here and let's say that I'm going to try
you know I need of course some handle on
how to set up my integral so maybe I'm
going to express things in terms of x
and y okay so I'm have my coordinates
and I'll try to use X&Y so then I would
like to relate Delta s D s to the area
in the XY plane so that means you know I
want maybe to look at the projection of
this guy onto a horizontal plane let's
squish it horizontally so then you have
here another area okay so the guy on the
slanted plane let's call that Delta s
and let's call this guy down here Delta
so the question and you know Delta a
would become ultimately nearly Delta X
Delta Y or something like that the
question is how do we find the
conversion rate between these two areas
see I mean they're not the same visually
I hope it's clear to you that if my
plane is actually horizontal then of
course we are the same but the more
slanted it becomes the more Delta a
becomes smaller than Delta s right I
mean if you buy you know if you buy land
and it's on the side of a cliff well
whether you get it on a map or whether
you look at it on the actual cliff the
area is going to be very different I'm
not sure if that's a wise thing to do if
you want to build a house where but I'm
event well you can get really cheap land
okay so anyway okay so Delta s versus
Delta a depends on how slanted things
are and let's try to make that more
precise by looking at the angle that our
plane makes with the horizontal
direction okay so
let's call this angle alpha the angle
that our plane makes with the horizontal
direction see it's all coming together
now the first unit about cross-product
normal vectors and so on is actually
useful now so I claim that the surface
element is related to the area in the
plane by Delta a equals Delta s times
the cosine of alpha why is that well
let's look at this small rectangle with
one horizontal side and one slanted side
when you project this side doesn't
change but this side gets shortened by a
factor of cosine alpha
whatever this length force this length
here is that one times cosine alpha so
that's why the area gets shrunk by
cosine alpha in one direction nothing
happens in the other direction you
squish by cosine alpha so what that
means is that well okay so we'll have to
deal with this and of course one will
care about actually is Delta s expressed
in terms of Delta a but what are we
going to do with this cosine you know
it's not very convenient to have a
cosine left in here so remember the
angle between two planes it's the same
thing as the angle between their normal
vectors so if you want to see this angle
alpha elsewhere what you can do is you
can just take the vertical direction
let's take K then here we have our angle
alpha again
well
so in particular cosine of alpha I can
get well we know how to find the angle
between two vectors right so if we have
our normal vector n we'll do n dot k and
we'll divide by length n length k well
length K is 1 that's one easy ok so
that's how we find the angle so now I'm
going to say well Delta s is going to be
1 over cosine Alpha Delta a and I can
rewrite that as length of n divided by n
dot K times Delta
now let's multiply that by the unit
normal vector because what we care about
is not so much D s but actually nd s so
and Delta s will be I'm just going to
multiply by n well let's think for a
second what happens if I take the unit
normal n and I multiplied by the length
of my other normal big n well I get big
n again all right this is a normal
vector of the same length as n well up
to sign but actually maybe I should the
only thing I don't know is whether this
guy will be going in the same direction
as big n or in the opposite direction
right say that for example my Capital n
has a length I don't know like 3 for
example then the unit normal vector
might be this guy in which K is indeed
three times little n will be big N or it
might be this one in which case three
times little n will be negative began
but up to sign it's N and then I will
have another n dot K Delta a and so the
final formula the one that actually we
care about you know in case you don't
really like my explanations of how we
get there
is that DS and DSi is plus or minus and
over n dot k DX dy that one is actually
kind of useful
so let's box it
now just in case you're wondering of
course if you didn't want to project to
x-y you would have maybe preferred to
project to save a plane of a blackboard
y'see well you can do the same thing
okay
to Express NDS in terms of dy DZ you do
the same argument and simply the only
thing that changes instead of using the
vertical vector K you use the normal
vector I so you would be doing n over n
dot I dy DZ and same thing okay so just
you know keep an open mind that this
also works with other variables but
anyway so that's how you can basically
project the vector surface area element
onto the XY plane in a way okay so let's
look at the special case just to see how
this fits with stuff we've seen before
let's do a special example where our
surface is given by the equation Z minus
f of X y equals zero okay that's a
strange way to write the equation Z
equals f of X y that we saw before but
now you know it looks like well some
function of X Y Z equals zero so let's
try to use this new method so let's call
this guy G of X Y Z well so now let's
look at the normal vector the normal
vector would be the gradient of G we
said what's the gradient of this
function so gradient of G well partial G
partial X that's just negative partial F
partial X gradient G sorry the Y
component partial G partial Y is going
to be negative F sub y and G sub Z is
just one so now if you take n of n dot k
DX dy well it looks like that's going to
be negative F sub X negative F sub y one
divided by well what's n dot k if you do
that with K you'll get just one so I'm
not going to write it the xt-1 see
that's again our favorite formula so
this one is actually more general
because you don't need to solve for Z
but if you cancel false even it's the
same as before
okay
I think that's enough formulas for NDS
so
after spending a lot of time telling you
how to compute surface integrals now I'm
going to try to tell you how to avoid
computing them
and that is called the divergence field
and we'll see the proof and everything
and applications on Tuesday but I want
to at least state for um and see how it
works in one example it's also known as
the girls main fear I'm ordered for
Gauss theorem depending on who you talk
to
so the green here is the same grain as
in Green's theorem okay because let's
somehow that's a space version of greens
theorem so what does it say it says so
it's a 3d analogue of green for flux
what it says is if s is a closed surface
okay so remember it's the same as with
greens theorem we need to have something
that's content completely enclosed so
you have a surface and there's somehow
no gaps in it there's no boundary to it
it's really completely enclosing a
region in space that I will call these
and I need to choose my orientation so
the orientation that will work for this
theorem is choosing the normal vector to
point outwards
okay so n needs to be outwards
so that's one part of a puzzle the other
part is a vector field I need to have a
vector field that's defined and
differentiable everywhere in d so same
instructions as usual then I don't have
actually to compute the flux integral
double integral of F dot NDS of a closed
surface s I'm going to put a circle just
to remind you it's got to be a closed
surface
that's just notation to remind us closed
surface I can replace that by the triple
integral over the region inside of
divergence of F DV now I need to tell
you what's the divergence of a 3d vector
field well you see it's not much harder
than in the 2d case what you do is just
so say that your vector field has
components P Q and R then you will take
P sub X plus Q sub y plus R sub Z okay
so that's the definition it's pretty
easy to remember you take the X
component partial respect to X plus
partial respect to Y over Y component
plus partial respect to Z of the Z
component okay so for example last time
we so add the flux of the vector field
ZK Oh sphere for sphere of radius-a was
4/3 PI a cubed by computing the surface
integral well if we do it more
efficiently now by greens theorem so
we're going to use greens theorem for
this this sphere because we doing the
whole sphere it's fine it's a closed
surface we couldn't do it for say your
hemisphere or something like that we
need to well I mean for the hemisphere
we need to add maybe the flat face at
the bottom or something like that
so the main theorem says that our flux
integral can be actually replaced by the
triple integral over of a solid ball of
radius a of the divergence of ZK DV but
now what's the divergence of this field
well so you have zero zero Z so you get
zero plus zero plus one looks like it
will be one so if you do the triple
integral of one DV you will get just for
volume
of the region inside which is 4/3 PI a
cubed and so it was no accident in fact
before that we looked at also X I plus
YJ plus ZK and we found 3 times of
volume that's because the divergence of
that field was actually three so very
quickly let me just say what this means
physically physically see this guy on
the left is the total amount of stuff
that goes out of the region per unit
time so I want figure out how much stuff
comes out of there what does the
divergence mean the divergence means
what it measures how much the flow is
expanding things it measures how much I
say probably when we understood to the
divergence it measures the amount of
sources or sinks that you have inside
your fluid so you know now it becomes
common sense if you take a region of
space the total amount of water that
flows out of it is the total amount of
sources that you have in there - for
sinks
okay I mean in spite of this
common-sense explanation I mean we are
going to see actually how to prove this
and we'll see how it works and what it
says